bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur arte france fabien lainé
vous avez voté pour le projet de loi sur
le pass vaccinale cette semaine quand
vous voyez ces cent mille manifestants à
travers la france expliqué qu'ils ne se
sentent plus en démocratie qu'ils se
sont insultés par les propos d' emmanuel
macron qui souhaitent je cite les
emmerder que ce pass vaccinale à créer
une sorte d'apartheid qu'est ce que vous
leur répondez
bien le soir
très excessifs
on voit que le pasa sanitaire qui a été
adoptée l'été dernier a été efficace
pour emmener les votes des défenses est
réticent fonds qui avaient peur à la
vaccination et on voit que après les
paroles des manuels macro ont certes
vivent un peu verte quand on voit que
nos compatriotes à nouveau autour ne se
faire vacciner
ce kit est assez frileux encore sur
cette opportunité là donc moi je m'en
réjouis il ya bien des propos qui ramène
les gens dans la rue et à qui les amène
notre pasteur estimé pas je pense pas
que ça soit ceux des prisonniers plus
raisonnablement
gilbert collard marine le pen elle a
voté contre le projet de loi sur le pass
vaccinale est ce que vous comprenez ces
manifestants l'ancien bras droit de
marine le pen florian philippot
organisateurs d'une des manifestations
cet après midi contre le passé actional
dénonce je cite le pays de la tyrannie
de la ségrégation négation ou en mai à
part à des millions de gens
si d'abord le pays de l'absurdité mais
avant tout je voudrais dire que je ne
suis pas anti vaccins moi je ne suis pas
contre les vaccins je suis pour que se
vaccine qui veut et ne se vaccinent pas
qui veut pour quelques raisons
la première c'est que ces vaccins je
crois qu'il faut le dire et là c'est le
modeste juristes qui s'expriment sont
toujours dans la période
d'expérimentation phase iii donc on n'a
pas le donner le ballon ne dit pas non
il aurait donné le ballon ils ont eu des
fanions de santé est un juriste vous
dites vous mais normal on me dit écoute
et or on nous écoute là vous si on va
prendre à prendre at vous affirmer que
ces vaccins ne sont plus en période
d'habilitation allez-y dit que l'on vous
écoute on vous enregistre à me faites
pas dire ce que je n'ai pas dit il donne
toujours des moments bon
alors laissez-moi continue les doigts
notre cantonner
les sépare les gilbert collard et après
vous aurez la parole pour terminer soyez
polis tenez vous bien je vous laisse
reparler vous avez la politesse de me
laisser parler ne fait pas le vilain
enfants après vous aurez la parole bon
donc sur le point très précis de savoir
s'ils sont ou non en période de
dévaluation vous avez craqué quand je
voulais demander d'acte est ce que vous
disiez donc ces vaccins sont encore à la
phase 3 on ne peut pas rendre
obligatoire un vaccin en phase 3 c'est
la raison pour laquelle le vaccin et
gilbert collard le vaccin n'est pas
encore obligatoire 1 mais voilà
attendait prenez moi pour un camp je
vous apprécierez le vaccin n'est pas
obligatoire et tout le monde est obligé
de se vacciner sinon on a un apartheid
vaccinale fait ça revient au même quoi
il y a à l'heure actuelle cinq mille
français qui ne sont pas vaccinés qui
vivent dans une situation très pénible
se font même insultée par le président
de la république sur le fondement d'un
vaccin attention là il ya consensus là
dessus maintenant le premier ministre
l'a dit qui ne vaccinent pas qui peut
atténuer les formes graves c'est
possible ça je veux bien le concéder
parce que c'est si possible mais il ne
vaccinent pas et on arrive à cette
solution absurde que le premier ministre
a concédé chez monsieur bourdin à savoir
qu' un individu
contaminés mais vacciner peut prendre le
train un individu pas contaminés mais
qui n'est pas vacciné bk un test négatif
ne peut pas prendre le train vous
comprenez on est on aurait un vaccin qui
vaquent side on ne serait plus en phase
expérimentale mais il serait absurde de
s'opposer absurde bon mais là je trouve
que ceux qui ont pris la décision
d'imposer le pas ce bac sida suivront
leurs responsabilités fabien lainé
fabien lainé justement répondait à
gilbert collard
je vous assure qu'on va assumer et on
assume déjà aujourd'hui on est en
responsabilité je vois que le sur le
sens de la nuance est toujours aussi
étranger et je le regrette un point
brillant juriste comme vous
évidemment que les peu que tous les
nouveaux traitements tous les nouveaux
traitements il ya toujours une phase
d'étude qui suit quand ils sont encore
récent même après leur mise sur le
marché c'est ce qui se passe sur le
médecin il faut bien qu'on évalue jamais
un un traitement a fait l'objet d'autres
l'étude que celui ci on a maintenant un
an et demi de recul tant qu un premier
test et vous le savez rien le dramatique
s'est passé pas de calais sur la rn les
sages et je parlais
percoler laisser parler fabien lainé qui
vous a laissé par les jeux vous aider
pour habiller les gars
mais oui bon
c'est normal de continuer à inspirer
nantais et de vax en phase iii série
d'autres médicaments qui sont mis sur le
marché il s'est dit que la france
empêche toutes les grandes démocraties
occidentales
aux unes aux autres autorités de la
santé qu'à valider ce d'accès bon et
quand on fait le bénéfice risque entre
aller en réanimation et yade et sur
certaines populations
il ya des risques qui sont pas
négligeables d'honneur animations sont
engagés hôpitaux dit quoi aux soignants
ont super vacciner les gens iront en
anglais et on justement justement fabien
lainé vous parler d'aidé soignant au
delà du du pass factionnelle ya la
réalité à l'hôpital aussi j'aimerais
qu'on en parle des centaines de blouses
blanches ont procédé hier à une minute
de silence à bordeaux à strasbourg
marseille de nombreuses villes de france
je cite pour alerter la mort annoncée de
l'hôpital public entre traits des
patients exacte des soignants conditions
dégradées pourtant emmanuel mails
emmanuel macron a dit cette semaine dans
le parisien qu'il n'y avait pas de tri
etc c'était juste une ligne rouge donc
qui croire fabien lainé les soignants ou
le président
l'utilité isuppli nos compatriotes de se
faire vacciner accueillir écouter les
écouter tout ce qu'ils nous disent pas
décemment ce qui vous arrange là vous
répondez pas à ma question puisque vous
parlez de la vaccination là je vous pose
la question sur l'état de l'hôpital qui
est en grande souffrance en
développement quelle est la majorité qui
a mis des moyens sans conséquence
octobre regardez de plus attendre je
vous mets au défi avec le c ur de la
santé les professionnels de santé
vital dans les ehpad ont été augmentés
sans conséquence sur moi c'est pas
suffisant mais c'est déjà le premier
abord on a supprimé les écologistes à
dire ce nombre de formations de maïs
s'inquiéter ça que chaque année revues à
la baisse c'était un dunk on a fait
sauter en penser que freddy produits de
santé pendant longtemps en forme en
moins de médecins on a le résultat qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui on a augmenté de 20
% les possibilités de formation des
infirmières sauf quand ça prend du temps
et nous on a pris nos responsabilités en
la demeure on n'a pas de responsabilité
donc aujourd'hui ce que vous allez me
dire si des délits qui sont fermés c'est
pas pour un intérêt économique c'est
parce qu'aujourd'hui il nous vous manque
des soignants donc voilà aujourd'hui
sont tombés en attendant en attendant
moi je comprends dit effectivement la
situation de l'hôpital mme gilbert
collard gilbert collard et marine le pen
a ajouté cette semaine présidente je
supprimerai se passe vaccinale c est ce
qu elle a coûté quelle solution alors
pour soulager les hôpitaux non mais il
faut il faut d'abord être très précis
rond on a le droit de tout dire bien sûr
mais en 2020 en pleine pandémie je dis
bien en pleine pandémie c'est acté dans
un rapport sénatorial que mon condo
ritter connaît on a supprimé 7000 700
lits vous vous rendez compte alors qu'il
y avait la guerre on a désarmé alors
qu'on avait besoin de lits qui sont donc
canon on les a supprimés c'est acté
c'est dans un rapport sénatorial tout le
nom de la ddt mais tout le monde le
reconnaît il vous avez un rapport qui
concerne l'ap-hp de paris
elle a perdu 1100 infirmiers par rapport
à 2010 ce qui a provoqué la fermeture de
1200 lits
[Musique]
en pleine pandémie mais c'est
catastrophique c'est quoi ce
gouvernement qui ne trouve comme
solution que d'imposer l'apartheid que
de traiter d'emmerdeur ceux qui
voudraient avoir la liberté en se
faisant tester de ne pas faire vacciner
vous avez employé un mot terrible tout à
l'heure on est même pas rendu compte
vous avez dit on peut expérimenter les
vaccins en phase 3 mais moi je vais vous
répéter ce que disait dupond moretti à
propos des détenus ils sont pas des
cobayes et ils n'ont pas à être ceux sur
qui on expérimente les vaccins c'est le
ministre de la justice de votre
gouvernement qui l'a dit alors ceux qui
pas valable pour les détenus c'est
valable pour les français on peut
expérimenter on sait ce n'est pas
n'importe quel médicament qui reste en
n'importe quel traitement on continue à
faire des écrits pendant des années
surtout quand ils sont récents mais on
nous expose
d'aller là vous comprenez vous je ne dis
pas vous allez forcément tort et quand
un médicament et dans période
expérimentale on ne on ne l'imposent pas
de force or c'est ce que vous avez fait
j'ai vite monsieur couleurs alors
qu'un jour ce qui s'est fait en hongrie
où madame le pen notre ami va
régulièrement mon pèlerinage là pour le
coup les il a précédé la france sur le
passage du ter bon voilà ils assistent
chaque jour un trio de faire vacciner
donc je m'étonne qu'il ya du beau
langage chantôme a envie on tient un
langage les cantons enfants sont notre
langage bon
on ne s'entend pas à les laisser
terminer fabien lainé si on oublait
gilbert collard
donc je je continue mon propos mais
chocolat vous savez très bien que l'on
dans une société on a des droits on a
des deux voies aujourd'hui le devoir de
nos compatriotes à d'obligations il ya
pas d obligation vaccinale mais leur
devoir céder sur bex clé et il faut des
impôts lisez ces urgences il ne faut de
plus on a pas on n'a pas fermé des lits
pour des raisons économiques aux
matières mais d'élus délit parce que de
soignants sont épuisés certains ont
quitté l'hôpital justement fabien lainé
si on n'avait pas fermé des lits
supplémentaires pendant la crise
sanitaire nom serait où vous voulez
devenir un de nombreux fans qui partent
d'ailleurs il ya de nombreuses fois nous
qui appelle à un plan marshall de la
part des différents candidats à la
présidentielle pour sauver l'hôpital il
dénonce le ségur de la santé dont vous
avez parlé 1,19 milliard d'euros
insuffisant qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez alors
son précédent la première majorité
depuis 30 ans qui met autant de moyens
dans l'habitat léger ça suffit pas
d'après ce que tous disent
on supprime 5700 lit enfin
saillants sont sur la peau pour dire que
ça se passe mal soyez soyez honnêtes
enfin quand même
vous l'écrivez comment vont former un
médecin réanimateur six mois
messieurs messieurs c'est peut-être
aussi parce que les conditions ne sont
pas là et qu'il faut peut-être un petit
peu plus et donner envie aux soignants
de devenir à à l'hôpital s'il vous plaît
monsieur s'il vous plaît laissez-moi
faire une observation ça fait deux ans
que la peine et que la pandémie frappe
ça fait deux ans depuis deux ans n'est
pas eu le temps de prendre la mesure et
d'adapter les mesures à la situation
depuis deux ans vous en êtes encore à
nous dire ah oui mais vous comprenez les
lions étaient fermés parce qu'à passer
de soignants mais qu'est-ce que vous
avez foutu pendant ces deux ans qu'est
ce que ça fait c'est démago c'est
malhonnête de dire ça me sort mais
qu'est ce que vous avez fait pendant ces
neuf cent des quelque 9 1% mais m on a
deux salles où on a pris nos
responsabilités on a supprimé les
mairies ce plausible on consomme
aujourd'hui en france sous emmanuel
macro ont vendu plus de soignants
qu'avant de se soigner
trouver des solutions
messieurs mais si on difficile difficile
de s'entendre quand vous parlez les deux
en même temps simplement pour terminer à
un mot de la fin rapidement pour pour
chacun en laissant parler l'autre
comment fabien lainé est ce que vous
qualifieriez cette journée de
manifestations en rappel un regain de
manifestants plus de cent mille
personnes dans les rues 121000 en
septembre deux cent trente sept mille le
7 août l'a de nouveau il ya des
personnes dans la rue alors que
le pass vaccinale va très certainement
pas c'est donc le 15 janvier prochain
j'ai bien vu tous ces gens dans la rue
qui est entre nous expliquer leur
liberté individuelle était plus
importante que l'intérêt général donc je
le regrette donc ils sont ramenés chacun
la responsabilité il fonde en plus tôt
10 emboliser l'hôpital par respect pour
les soignants et je le rappelle chacun à
la responsabilité
je regarde ce qui se passe dans les
autres pays européens jouent un pays qui
fait mieux que nous
pour gilbert collard rapidement elle
fiabilité du nord si je pense que on y
gagnera dans la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire voilà
on sait que le vaccin ne vaccinent pas
on sait qu'il peut atténuer les formes
graves cependant on impose à une
population de 5000 personnes à peu près
des mesures coercitives qui ont choqué
quand choqué la défenseure des droits ça
tout le monde s'en fout mais elle a
quand même dit que c'était scandaleux ce
qui se passe est bon l'hôpital
a était délabré on a supprimé 5710 dont
nous dit que tout a été fait mais
pendant deux ans depuis que la pandémie
sévit on n'a rien fait si ce n'est
rogner jour après jour les libertés des
citoyens moi je suis pas anti vaccins
suis pas anti vaccins je le dis je le
répète ceux qui veulent se faire
vacciner allez vous faire vacciner mais
je voudrais que ceux qui ne le veulent
pas puisse ne pas le faire or vous avez
organisé une une tyrannie sanitaires et
ça ce n'est pas acceptable du point de
vue du droit hmm hmm messieurs messieurs
merci d'avoir répondu à une question
merci pour ce débat très vif dont contre
deux deux personnalités opposées fabien
lainé député modem des landes et gilbert
collard heureux député du rassemblement
national